[Musique]
quand le château de jean claude brialy à
monthyon jean pierre melville tourner le
cercle rouge avec alain delon yves
montand et bourvil qui entre deux prises
de vue nous parlent eux aussi de leurs
projets pour 1970 on va tourner à cette
année je reviens à de vieilles amours le
film policier d' aventure physique avec
des hommes là pas de femmes dans mon
film je n'ai pas fait exprès je ne suis
pas misogyne mais en écrivant le
scénario tout à coup je me suis aperçu
qui avait pas de place pour les femmes
alors il n'y en aura pas il y à de longs
bourvil montant jian maria volonté
françois périer
[Applaudissements]
c'est beaucoup trop bonne avance encore
p merci ya d'abord la sortie de
borsalino ça c'est un projet je veux
dire c'est une réalité ça c'est même
très bientôt c'est le 20 mars que j'ai
fait en tant que producteur et acteur
et puis à ce film que j'aime commencer
soit direction de melville cercle rouge
et puis j'ai un autre projet très
important pour la fin de l'année
proust c'est la direction de l'iss conti
pour alain et pour me sens parfait d'une
présence physique exceptionnel on peut
lui demander de faire des choses de
précisions bon pour moi ont la double
c'est encore un personnage en marge de
la société
je sais c'est encore en faire sourire
certains puisque on me reproche toujours
de jouer ce genre de rôle mais dans ce
film c'est un peu spécial est un film de
melville et veut dire sur les actions de
jean pierre melville
je suis prêt à affronter n'importe quel
personnage même si les personnages que
j'ai déjà fait de toute façon c'est
aucun projet pour la c1 présent séquence
aux gens disent on va voir trois films
que j'aurais tourné et je pense que
trois jeunes dans l'année c'est
amplement suffisant
d'une part et que d'autre part c'est
aussi très important de ne pas tourner
sans arrêt c'est important c'est de
prendre un certain recul et de se
nourrir aussi intérieurement on va voir
la ve qui doit sortir et simplement au
mois de mai avril
ensuite vous aurez ces deux films avec
barbra streisand que je tournais en
année dernière à hollywood qui s'appelle
par un jour sans nuages on peut voir
jusqu'à l'infini
et puis le cercle rouge que nous
prendrons en ce moment qu'est-ce que
vous jouez dans le cercle un tueur
d'élite un tireur d'élite
je dire qu'on a besoin de ses talents de
tireur paul ii vraiment délicat faire
lever d'une grande précision cesser ces
scénarios sont toujours des coupes et
d'une façon au millimètre près mais sans
se laisser prendre lui même à cette
mécanique c'est à dire que sa colonne
vertébrale est parfaitement bien
bien écrite mais ils se permettent à
entendre de naviguer à l'intérieur du
surf
il n'a pas peur de couper ou d'enlever
ou dans la vie quand membres dialogue si
l'image est beaucoup plus forte que je
connais dit le revolver demi heure ne
partez pas tout de suite mieux regarder
le partir vallée monsieur amyot les
lotos
[Musique]
la grue les inspecteurs marché beaucoup
plus vite que ça sorte est venu vers moi
à toute pompe les inspecteurs les
gendarmes ne pourrait pas
[Musique]
la 403
cette saison
je suis un commissaire de police et
c'est moi qui ait montant de l'an c'est
un film dramatique bon
la nuit tellement beau le principal que
ça ah oui je couche avec 2
[Musique]